從十萬翻到數千萬
這個過程大概歷時多久
七個月了
因為剛好搭上了這一波
散戶的船局
全鎮的大哥不是小哥
像我們這種非科班出身的
到底要怎麼訓練極短線的教育
我也是非科班
其實好好研究策碼就可以了
4月7號的重挫
4月8號又重挫
兩天合起來有三千多點
我本來一早打算去雨田川
看櫻花妹的
那結果那行情太大了
就跟我太太说
今天不行 今天出不了门
台股的前景觉得堪忧
投资的思维上面有没有什么调整
我这年龄 我总不能再归零了
你只要有开杠杆
一定要有空单滑过
少年古神他就是喜欢欧益
这种二十几岁
假如没有靠家里很快到上亿的
他的避险做得比较少
市场上有很多散户
埋进0050长线抱着的投资人
你会给什么建议
欢迎收看收听理财之优生
我是曼妮前总编辑国联
曾经是学校老师
没有父爸爸
也没有商学的背景
靠着自学筹码
配合操作高杠杆的权证
用十万滚出千万
37岁的时候转换跑道
全新成为全职的交易者
除了权证交易
他也结合了技术面筹码
由权证扩大到现股
股票取货跟可转债的套利交易
这个散户传奇就是权证小哥
欢迎小哥
嗨 国联好 各位好
我是全职小哥
以前是学校老师
以前我教理化 现在教理财
那我在西班里里面设计软体
那也有在上课
那说全职教育也没有啦
因为还有上课的关系
那我还蛮喜欢上课的
可能是从以前就是在学校教的关系
那我有一些学生
他以前是
我是他的理化老师兼导师
他现在是
每次我上理财课
他都会来上
等于是从学校教到社会
对不对
你是那个散户的船局
全镇的大哥不是小哥
那你现在一天的交易量有多少
因为交易量要看行情
例如说在
跳风涨前跟跳风银前
那天就没什么交易量
像今天波动很大
今天大概就可以做到三四亿
小哥
我知道那个4月7号的时候
你人虽然在日本
台股重挫
但是你还是有参与台股的交易
而且4月7号这一波这样下来
其实你是赚的
可以跟我们分享一下
你是怎么看
怎么定策略
怎么操作的
好 那我们要先讲到4月7号
一早发生什么时候
其实4月6号
我大概估算了一下
台股隔天开盘大概跌9%
因为我们从负实指数去回推
它在跌9%
那跌9%呢
大概就还好嘛
就是还有流动性嘛
结果隔天一早开盘
小纳又跌5%
那小纳跌5%
你再回推那个9%
哇塞 那台子期会跌14%
假设我们跟小纳跌5差不多的话
那我就说 哇 这天会出市
其实我现在想想我还是犯的错
因为当天一开盘
盘前我应该把所有的库存
全部一键出清
因为盘前你看市场
你就看得出来
应该大概率都跌停了
那我这盘前我想说
不行啦 我一键出清
又让这个股有那么大卖压
还是算了 我就没有先一见促清
不过一开盘之后呢
我就去找那个还有流动性的商品来做
当天还有流动性商品呢 就两个
一个是选择权 一个是权证
那4月7号那一天呢
我们就是先下选择权跟权证嘛
先选择权 再多币钱
所以选择权 我去买了一些
选择权的卖权
我甚至还去锁那个卖权的涨顶
卖权的涨顶把我全收了这样
因為那個賣錢算起來很划算
那夜盤就可以出掉
我本來一早打算去雨田川看櫻花妹的
因為有櫻花跟櫻花妹嘛
那本來講一早就出門
那結果那行情太大了
我就跟我太太說
今天不行 今天出不了門了
早上我們先在這個房間裡
先把一些交易把它做好
所以當天我就買了很多選擇權跟權證
那那一次4月7號的重錯
4月8號又重錯
两个合起来有三千多点
这样子一路下来
小哥是赚还是赔
这样讲 我的库存肯定是赔的
因为库存我们是
波段多加短空
那当天短空也不用做了
所以当天我是买了选择权 买了权证
那我们说这个新建的部位
大概赚了两百多万
那库存的部位当然是赔钱
所以你必须要在这市场上
你要懂很多商品
你要懂选择权权证懂海棋
你假如懂不懂的话
你只会去买一个不大合理的价格
例如说礼拜一
你去买0050
那个价格不合理
因为它是跌停缩时的
它有隐含着
还要再打个95折
那礼拜四你去买0050
那非常合理
因为呢它是涨停缩时的
你买到的话
它事实上有意涵的
它这个后面还有一个涨幅
我去推算大概还有三四%
就因為夜盤表現不好
所以導致0050更多沒有開高
但是都沒關係
因為我們在禮拜四的白天
我們可以在選擇權
去鎖我們所要的獲利
10月12號盤選
我掛了1000張的0050
因為4月12號那天台子起漲停
那漲停呢
我掛0050大概只能用抽籤的
所以那天我大概我記得抽到了
大概40張左右
中40的時候
我就去那個
副實指數那邊做避險
那我也有在選擇權那邊做避險
所以呢
我的0050事實上
做完避險
它的利潤我已經鎖住了
那4月11號呢
0050沒有預期的開高
不過我避險那部分就打磚
那這些東西我們都寫在書上
各位呢 你可以多看書
我們的這個全程小的終極戰法
裡面有各個商品怎麼做
還有像這個可乘的籌碼狀況
這裡面都有寫
小哥的意思是說
要先把知識建立起來
把所有的工具都搞懂
去了解他們的一些所謂的運作的慣性
對 你可以
其實你這些商品都懂
你就可以推算出來
例如說在禮拜一的時候
我們可以推算出來
台子期約末還有5%的跌幅
那在禮拜四我們就可以推算出來台子期約末還有3%的漲幅那你這個推算得出來的話你就可以去做相對應的策略小哥好像不是第一次遇到這種狀況對不對
不是 因為我們在
這種有流動性的問題
所以我們說
這次的崩盤是史詩級別的
有流動性問題
漲跌停所指的
我只有在2009年
然後2009年的
這個4月30號有看過
喔 記得這麼清楚
對 因為那一次是那個
中國要入主遠傳
中國移動要入主遠傳
那這個利多就變成一個
兩岸大和協的那種利多
所以當天夜盤磨台漲15%
那當夜盤磨台漲15%
隔天當然很多股票漲停
那很多股票漲停
你可以做事
像我那天我就買了一堆全震
那時候全震呢
還可以去算一下
買價一塊錢
賣價1.02 1.03 1.04
都全吃了
因为隔天还会涨停
所以那种卖价很接近的
你都全吃都没问题
因为隔天涨停
反映在全顿上
可能全顿还有
那个四五十%的涨幅
那你那一次赚多少
那一次我们的资产
因为隔天我就all in了
all in
因为大阪涨停
很多人股票买不到
他都没买
结果隔天买了一堆全顿
all in完之后呢
在隔天就从400多
就变800多了
2009年那一次的大赚
对于你的投资生涯
有影響嗎
非常大的影響
因為那一次是一個很大的跳躍
因為從400到800
然後很快的就上千了
那上千之後也累積蠻快的
累積到後面
被動收入就超過這個薪水
就要離職了
所以那天很重要
所以這一個是
你等於是人生第一次輝煌的戰役
對
但是其實在輝煌戰役之前
你曾經資產歸零過三次
對 歸零大概就是
買股票賠一賠
赔到没什么钱再买了
那就算归0一次
没有说真的到0
第一次是买股票
买股票买一买
那时候买华印
华印就觉得说
这么便宜的电子股
想不到更烂
华印买一波赔了一段
后来想说
没什么钱
来玩个选择权好了
选择权也是
投进去之后
也没多久就没有了
最后剩下50万就去买全赠
那全震也不曉得
时间价值流失的问题
那一包爆很久
后面也归零了
所以呢
这前三次归零是这样
不过都有钱吃饭
但是这三次的归零
是不是奠基你在2009年
那一次的成功
对啊
因为归零之后就要想
我的质上也没有那么低啊
为什么做股票做要赔钱
那就好好想说
到底是哪里面出了问题
像我就研究
全震研究人头车
我大概都知道说
它的报价会在哪个位置
就是我一看就知道说
这个价格呢
明天涨一%在哪里
涨两%在哪里
那我在心里面都可以算出来
就是因为之前那样的经历造成的
那我可以算出它的合理价
我就知道说哪些价格是合理
哪些价格不合理
从全正市场上就很快的
就从十万翻了千万
翻到数千万
这个过程大概历时多久
七个月而已
因为刚好搭上了这一波
其实就是4月30号那一天蛮重要的
因為4月30號之前是10萬到400萬
再經過4月30號以後就跳上去了
哇 小哥 你這麼多年累積寫成書
那這麼多年這樣累積下來
你大概在學習過程當中
你一天大概花多少時間
幾乎是沒什麼在看電視的
就是每一次在家裡都是在看重馬黑
不過我記得
我2008年前
這個NBA哪一年誰得冠軍
我大概都知道
2008年以後
這個開始研究股票之後
一直到2012年
2013年開始有籌碼K之後
那個看球的時間顯著的減少
所以那幾年
我記得這個季賽
我大概都沒什麼在看
都可能在看冠軍賽而已
所以一天大概有花個
12小時在研究股票嗎
加盤中時間肯定是有的
像小哥是很擅長做極短線交易的
這個極短線的交易
讓人家感覺就是開盤的時候
就是在電腦上在那邊不斷的點點
跟一般人的投資操作的印象很不一樣
到底怎麼樣做極短線
極短線其實我們會利用
當充神器的連次量
因為極短線我們在抓轉折或抓發動
那當充的連次量這樣子
第一次的最大量
第一次的很大量 那個是發動量
那可能十几次 二十几次
那十几次是说
例如说它连续外盘攻击十几次
我们指的一次是说5秒一次
我们是5秒统计一次
5秒统计一次是说
这次这5秒内外盘成交量跟内盘成交量
看哪一个多
那假如连一次外盘成交量获胜的话
它就连一次红色
那假如连到十几次代表说
哇 这个买盘已经连胜十几次了
你可以把它想像成
多軍跟空軍在廝殺
那多方已經連勝十幾次了
到後面就容易有一個買盤結晶
多軍跟空軍在廝殺
是每五秒就有一個結果
每五秒就有一個結果
在我們的那個
當中診訊裡面
它會每五秒統計一次
讓你看結果
例如說這五秒內
第一次兩千張的多方量
那這個就是攻擊量
那可以問一下你RQ的問題嗎
所謂極短線的交易
到底時間多短
可以短到一兩秒就結束
像有些股票
這個在多方攻擊的時候
有時候它會短時間內
漲幅超過3.5%
大概兩分鐘內漲幅超過3.5%
這時候會進入一個緩挫
那緩挫完呢
這個緩挫完通常會在一個高點做結束
那有時候我們都會去空這個緩挫
高點的位置
直接就空它了
直接空它
那空完之後它會瞬間下沙
瞬间下站那一刻
直接又补掉
哇
所以这个时间有时候才一两秒而已
所以反应要很快 收腰很快
对 反应很快
就是从小是打电动
都已经训练过了
像我们这种非科班出身
到底要怎么训练
可以做到这样的一个
极端线的教育呢
我也是非科班嘛
所以其实好好研究抽码就可以
其实我们都要讲研究抽码很重要其实这个隔天黑黑就是我们常讲的只要今天大买的是隔日筹
大卖的是大股东
那么隔天就容易黑黑
那各位你就可以去研究筹码
看今天大买的是不是隔日筹
大卖的是不是大股东
筹码这件事情
我知道小哥很重视
但是有那种反筹码派的
都说筹码会骗人
小哥看筹码
刚刚有举例的对不对
那那个秘诀
或者是有没有特别的地方
可以教我们的
其实我蛮欣赏这种
会反对筹码的
因为我们在市场上就缺对手
就缺对手
因为假如大家都跟我们
都学筹码 那完蛋了
市场上玩
没有对手你知道吗
你要卖股票
你发现
你所有的学员都跟你一起卖股票
那完蛋了
你总是要有一些人
他是想買股票的
那所以呢
我們喜歡
有人跟我的想法不一樣
最好不一樣
有沒有什麼美感
就大方向教我們一下
大方向是這樣子
這籌碼它有分長線跟短線
長線短線
那長線呢
舉例來說像可成這檔股票
它長線而言呢
我們有去計算過
可成的台南分點
这十几年来 不算股息
光算价差
在可成赚了200多亿以上
就是你看得到的前数名
赚了200多亿以上
那当然后面还有一些分点你看不到
所以呢 可成呢
只要低档关键大买
那都是一个很好的买点
然后它做波段呢 可以做得很长
我像可成我讲了五年了
我从2020年买到现在
買到現在 為什麼
因為它的波段分點
還沒有大幅出托
所以就買到現在
那你看這波可乘
關稅帝君這樣二稿之下
可乘它很快的又回到
出事之前的位置
基本面你可能看不出來
但是我們光從籌碼面來看
這點就是低點
所以買了也不用太擔心
剛剛小哥在跟我聊天的時候
有聽到說
波段的話你會做波段多
也不斷空单
可是在短线的部分
你只做空单
短线会做短多跟短空
短多比较会做地盘股
那短空就是
像刚刚讲的那个案例
就是隔日冲遇到大股东
那隔日冲大买
然后大股东大卖
他隔天
隔天再涨
大股东还会卖
隔日冲也要卖
那就容易跌了
短线的交易不是那么容易
那小哥虽然18班无意都会
可是我特别想要
请小哥分享一下
在短线交易这个部分
有哪些必定要做的功课
你才能成为
短线交易的常胜君
每天都要看重马K
每天你都要看一下
今天买超分点是哪几个
卖超分点是哪几个
然后他们买卖的价位
他们的手法
每天研究
每天看
比如说买超低迷
它的惯性是怎么样
买超低迷
可能新加坡瑞
摩根大通
或者凯基山崇
凯基台北
你看一下他的惯性
惯性很重要
他的惯性假如是连买
那这张股票就是波段多
你要看他惯性
就是他前一天的行为是怎么样
他假如他的行为都是
一买一卖
那今天大买
隔天有大几率会卖
就是第一个看惯性就可以
可是这个就很重要
那第二个高档的时候
你要看一下
有没有卖超大分点在狂卖
那只要有卖超大分点狂卖
那这张股票后面就是会跌下来
因为大股东获利了结
后面一定要有人来洗碗
一定要有人买单
那买单的人就在高点追股票的人
你没有看筹码
很难做
因为我们常讲
有些股票的K棒
跟K棒还有技术指标
你怎么看都是隔天要做多的
但是你一看筹码就知道
隔天要做空
我们在讲那个做当中交易
当中交易很简单
它就是一个
你去猜红K还是黑K的过程
但很多人做当中
他都喜欢猜红K
他喜欢先买再买
但红K事实上是很难猜的
你很难猜得出来这张股票
今天红K的几率有多高
但是你去猜黑K呢
它的几率是会
是比较好猜
那黑K这个
你就可以由筹码去算得出来
那我在当中课
我一直常提到一個案例
這很多人去澳門啊 去賭場啊
他都會去玩百家樂
百家樂就是去拆那個莊家跟賢家
那你可以把它
他想成莊家是紅K 賢家是黑K
我說你連一點訊息都沒有
你都敢下賭場玩了
你不如來玩台股啊
台股你有很多訊息可以看啊
對不對 你有籌碼可以看
你可以知道說
今天買超分點是不是隔日充
你可以知道說他有沒有錢高
或者是這個有沒有波段的賣壓
這些你從籌碼都看得到
你拆對的機率就會大幅提高
那拆對機率提高之後
你每天要做的事情就是
多打幾個部位
因為你多打幾個部位
你的勝率就會升高
你只打一檔
你的勝率是沒那麼高
多打幾個勝率就會提高
小哥常常上課
最近會不會有學生請教你
就是說怎麼看台股的未來
美國美債是個蠻大的問題
美債
還有川普的關稅
依照川普的個性呢
他又是如此的變動
所以我覺得目前
行情整體看起來是堪憂的
除非台灣談到一個很好的稅率
就日本20% 台灣5%
類似這一種
就是我們的稅率可以比鄰國
都來得優惠的話
那不然的話
整體的大環境
我覺得是要小心的
既然對台股的前景覺得堪憂
小哥在投資的思維上面
或者是策略做法上面
有沒有什麼調整
像我以前
我的空單避險大概佔個兩層
那我現在會拉高到五層
你只要有開槓桿
一定要有空單保護
你的戶頭只要有融資
你一定要搭配一些融券或是搭配一些不大会跌的现股科转债科转债是这种不大会跌当你融资维持率出市的时候这些现股这些科转债它都可以让你提高你的维持率
那你假如开杠杆
你买期货的话
你期货不能全部都多单了
你一定要空单在里面保护
那像我的多单
例如说可乘我现在有很多多单
那我就相对应的
我可能大台那边就会空一些
等于是说小哥现在
在风险控制上面更谨慎
更谨慎
然后我的现金部位会提高
那如果以你整个资产组合配置来讲的话
你先前的杠杠比例大概是多少
现在杠杠比例大概到两倍
就是说我的所有现金
我的部位大概可能是我
所有现金
就是可用现金的两倍
那现在我已经把它降到一倍以下
就这些部位我都可以变现
这些部位我都可以用现金去持有
但是我还是喜欢杠杆
因为呢
而这部位我用杠杆去持有
我还是可以有一个很大部位的现金
那这些大部位的现金呢
可以在某些状况
你可以进场去
比如说抄底
或者是有些不合理的价格
你就可以去买这样子
我们在业界在房间都听到很多
有听到一个最近有上媒体的一个案例
说有个才26岁
他是赚到上亿了
赚到上亿了
然后他这次就整个归零了
那其实我是估算了
像他这种二十几岁
假如没有靠家里
很快到上亿的
通常他的避险做的比较少
你的速度越快
代表你都是避险做的少
那像我们速度没那么快
因为每次我们都会做避险
我们追求安定
我这年龄
我也总不能再归零了吧
我这年龄归零那还得了
对不对
所以我们是追求安定
追求资产是稳健的上升
所以我们不会做全部all in的动作
那这个少林股神他就是喜欢all in
那喜欢电构机all in
这种翻得很快
但也摔得很快
因为这种例子我们看过太多了
因为你这么冲
你每次都杠杆都开个五六倍
那只要一个大事件
很容易就回来
你杠杆开五倍
回挡个20%你就没有了
杠杆你像毒品一样
吃了会上瘾
所以呢
我们都建议你开杠杆可以
你一定要有相对应的反向部位
或者是你的部位要复杂一点
你最好可能可以放到
五档股票或十档股票
那这五档股票里面呢
可能有三多两空
那这十档股票里面
可能六多四空
七多三空
那这样子遇到这种系统性的风险
什么叫系统性风险
全面跌停 全面涨停
这就是系统性的风险
遇到系统性的风险出现的时候
你的维持率不会出问题
维持率出问题代表你的户头
已经掌握在别人手中了
人家可以一秒八年部位全部砍掉
这个我是觉得最容易失败的案例
就是你没办法你的部位给控管
现在市场变动这么大
小哥也常常做短线交易
或者是一些
全症的操作杠杆交易
这个压力很大
投资人最容易
在这样高度压力之下
遇到什么问题
就容易变胖
因为身体的机制
当你遇到压力的时候
身体就会帮你多囤点脂肪
因为他会认为说
你要遇到危难了
所以做交易的人
很容易变胖
那很容易变胖
就是你要吃得健康一点
多运动
我一直在减肥
一直想要减肥
我们知道小哥是一个交易型的投资人
但是其实台湾市场上有很多散户
他是买进持有的长线投资者
那0050又是大家最爱之一
对于像这种
喜欢买进0050长线抱着的投资人
你会给什么建议
我觉得
我觉得0050 ETF
也蛮好的
但是
自己组ETF更好
自组ETF更好
就是你去找一些
低档关键买高值利润股票
整体而言它的表现
我觉得会比0050还会更好
可是表现这波就比0050好很多
但是这些散户
他们可能不会自己调股票
那就好好的来看这本书
分点学好
为什么
因为这种市值型的ETF
在历经一个大股灾
它也是会有一个大幅度的回档
那除非你对这种回档
是不会在意的
不会在意的说
假设我问一个很假的问题
假设这波跟08年一样
打个试着
60%不见了
那你看到这个户头
买那只60%
你会不会心痛想砍股票
那假如不会的话OK
那你就继续买0051
因为它毕竟还是会再涨回来
砍不下去
是砍不下去
那也OK
你砍不下去也OK
我就怕你在低档把它砍了
因为有很多人
一开始砍不下去
但在560%
在绝望的那一天
它砍得下去
它砍下去
那就可惜了
他就失去了他这个
投资市值型ETF的意义了
好 所以从小哥刚刚回答
我们有两个结论
第一个是
如果你可以自主ETF
然后找到高值率率又便宜的个股
你可以这样做
可是如果你没有办法自己挑选股票
你要买0050也可以
像2008年金融海啸
股市打市者
那要抱得住
要抱得住
就是要有耐心
要有耐心
各位观众跟听众朋友们
对于小哥所说的
台股的前景可能堪忧这件事情
如果你买0050
你会长报还是现代座做调整呢
都欢迎在留言区告诉我们
今天谢谢小哥精彩的分享
我是国联理财之优生
我们下次见
拜拜
字幕志愿者 杨茜茜